Transcription: Hanna Vandenberghe
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous êtes-vous déjà restreint d’indiquer
une de vos passions sur votre CV ?
C'était mon cas jusqu'à récemment.
J’ai beaucoup de passions.
Comme beaucoup :
le sport, la musique, les voyages,
mais aussi le jeu vidéo.
J’avais du mal à donner de la valeur
à cette dernière passion
d’un point de vue professionnel.
Je me suis dit que c’était bête
car j’ai plein de choses à en dire
qui sont aussi intéressantes
que sur mes autres passions.
Alors je l’ai mis,
j’ai rajouté une petite ligne « e-sport :
joueur et coach compétitif. »
Suite à cet ajout,
j’ai eu pas mal de réactions
plutôt mitigées, voire négatives,
de la part de différents recruteurs
ou professionnels.
Je n’étais pas étonné
puisqu’il y a une barrière générationnelle
qui est très forte à ce sujet,
en France tout du moins,
et les a priori
sont difficiles à combattre.
Mais je pense qu’ils ont eu tort.
Je pense que le jeu vidéo
a beaucoup à apporter
au monde de l’entreprise.
Pour arriver à cette conclusion,
il faut comprendre à quoi sert un CV.
Il sert à démontrer
un certain nombre de compétences,
de qualités qu’on pense avoir
et qui nous rendent apte
à un poste spécifique.
Dans ce contexte, la section « passions »,
elle sert à montrer
des qualités humaines :
le savoir-être, la transitivité
des qualités du monde des sports
ou de la musique vers
le monde de l’entreprise,
c’est quelque chose
qui est recherché et admis par tous.
Quand des recruteurs ont pu lire
par exemple « conservatoire » sur mon CV,
ils ont probablement pensé « abnégation ».
Lorsqu’ils ont lu « rugby », ils ont
peut-être pensé « esprit d’équipe ».
Le souci, c’est qu’ils n’ont rien
associé de positif
à ma pratique des jeux vidéo
et c’est normal étant donné que
la plupart des informations
qui atteignent le grand public
aujourd’hui sur ce sujet
concernant généralement
les risques du jeu vidéo,
que ce soient
des risques réels ou fantasmés.
Pourtant, je pense que le jeu vidéo est
un vecteur d’apprentissage fantastique,
au même titre que des instruments,
du sport ou du poker.
Prenons par exemple le jeu Baba Is You.
C’est un jeu indépendant
qui est sorti il y a environ deux ans.
Le but de ce jeu,
c’est de déplacer un personnage
et de résoudre des énigmes, des puzzles
en s’aidant d’un certain nombre de règles
qui sont affichées à l’écran.
Ces règles sont les règles
du code informatique,
ce qui veut dire que
d’avancer dans le jeu,
de passer des niveaux,
oblige le joueur, le pousse à intégrer,
à apprendre ces règles
d’une manière qui est
beaucoup plus intuitive,
beaucoup plus naturelle
que ne pourrait le faire,
par exemple, un cours magistral.
Aujourd’hui, je suis persuadé
que ce jeu est l’outil le plus efficace
pour initier quelqu’un,
quel que soit son âge,
au code ou à l’informatique,
de manière générale.
Une heure de Baba Is You, c’est
des heures de cours d’Excel en moins.
C’est plus efficace, plus économique
et quand même beaucoup plus amusant.
Prenons maintenant
les jeux appelés stratégiques,
des jeux qui ont deux caractéristiques
communes principales.
La première : ce sont
des jeux multijoueurs en ligne
et la deuxième,
ce sont des jeux dans lesquels
le but est de battre un adversaire.
Ces deux caractéristiques mises ensemble,
ça pousse à la création
de ce qu’on appelle l’e-sport.
C’est une scène compétitive, issue du jeu.
L’e-sport est quelque chose
d’assez nouveau en Europe.
Il n’y a pas beaucoup
de législation dessus
et ce n’est pas forcément
très grand public,
mais ce n’est pas le cas
partout dans le monde.
L’avant-garde à ce sujet
se situe en Corée du Sud
où, depuis plus de 20 ans,
il y a des chaînes télévisées
qui sont spécialisées dans la diffusion
ou la rediffusion des matches e-sportifs,
d’une même manière qu’on peut avoir
des chaînes sportives en France.
De plus, dans ce pays,
avoir mis sur son CV un bon niveau,
avoir réussi à avoir un bon classement
ou réussir des bons challenges
sur des jeux vidéo,
ça a la même valeur sur le CV
pour beaucoup de recruteurs
qu'une bonne expérience professionnelle
ou qu'une bonne école.
Un bon exemple de ça,
ça va être la finance de marché
qui est allée recruter en masse
des anciens joueurs
professionnels de Starcraft,
qui était le jeu compétitif majeur
de la décennie 2000 en Corée de Sud.
Des recruteurs sont allés chercher
dans ces joueurs professionnels
des traders ou des gens
pour différents postes
dans la finance de marché.
On peut se demander pourquoi,
c’est simplement parce que,
par la pratique de leur jeu vidéo,
ils avaient développé
à la fois des bonnes compétences
de microgestion
et ils avaient
une bonne résistence à la pression
et à des environnements rapides tels que
rencontrés dans la finance de marché.
Dans un exemple plus proche de nous,
dans le temps et dans l’espace,
on peut avoir le joueur SeleCT
qui est issu du même jeu Starcraft
et qui, récemment, s’est vu offrir
un poste de stage,
puis de CDI aux États-Unis,
directement par le PDG de Shopify,
entreprise que vous connaissez peut-être.
S’il s’est vu offrir ce poste,
ce n’est pas grâce
à son école d’ingénieurs,
mais plutôt grâce
à son expérience e-sportive
qui l’avait amené à être connu par ce PDG
et dans laquelle il avait pu montrer
un certain nombre de compétences
et de qualités dont le PDG de Shopify
estimait qu’elles étaient
importantes et essentielles
pour qu’il devienne
ingénieur au sein de son entreprise.
Qu’est-ce que peuvent voir ces recruteurs,
ces professionnels en Corée,
aux États-Unis ou ailleurs
qu’on semble peu ou pas voir en France ?
Ce que cherche un recruteur aujourd’hui,
surtout chez des jeunes comme nous,
c’est avant tout des soft skills.
Jamais aucun recruteur ne m’a demandé
si je tenais dans une mêlée,
malgré mes un mètre 70 et mes 60 kilos.
C’est contestable, mais voilà,
je ne tiens pas dans une mêlée,
peu importe, ça ne l’intéresse pas.
Ce qui l’intéresse, c’est de savoir
quelles sont les capacités humaines,
les capacités que j’ai pu
retirer de ce sport
et qui vont lui être utiles
dans son entreprise.
Et je pense qu’il faut appliquer
la même logique à tous les sports,
toutes les passions et aussi l’e-sport.
Les compétences peuvent être diverses
selon le jeu auquel on joue,
de la même manière qu’elles sont diverses
selon le sport qu’on peut pratiquer.
Une danseuse étoile et un joueur de foot
n’auront pas du tout développé
les mêmes compétences,
les mêmes qualités
selon le sport qu’ils pratiquent.
Et malgré ça, on peut essayer de trouver
un lien, un socle entre tous les athlètes,
qu’ils soient sportifs ou e-sportifs.
Rick Fox en parle beaucoup mieux que moi.
C’est un ancien joueur de NBA,
donc un sportif professionnel
qui s’est beaucoup investi dans l’e-sport
ces dernières années
et qui a été beaucoup au contact
d’athlètes e-sportifs.
Et dans ce cadre, il a pu repérer
un certain nombre de similitudes
entre les athlètes sportifs et e-sportifs.
Et il le dit lui-même que
ce sont des athlètes numériques.
Ce sont des athlètes professionnels.
Il leur a fallu beaucoup d’investissement,
beaucoup de temps de concentration,
de préparation pour devenir
les athlètes qu’ils sont aujourd’hui.
En plus de ces qualités humaines
et qualités tout court
qui forment le socle de ces athlètes,
on peut aussi repérer
des compétences très spécifiques.
Pour voir ça, on va essayer
de prendre l’exemple
d’un jeu qui est très complexe,
mais on va essayer de simplifier
pour voir les similarités de réflexion
entre ce jeu et le monde de l’entreprise.
Devant vous, vous pouvez voir deux écrans.
A gauche, l’interface
du jeu « Age of Empire »,
un jeu de stratégie assez connu.
Et à droite, vous pouvez voir l'interface
de Microsoft Project.
Microsoft Project, c’est un logiciel
de gestion de projet
qui lui aussi est très connu.
Vous pouvez voir deux choses
qui vous semblent
très différentes au premier abord,
mais moi, j’y vois la même chose.
Dans les deux cas,
il y a une barre de ressources.
A gauche, avec des pierres,
de la nourriture, du bois.
A droite, ça va être des hommes,
des grues, des machines.
Dans les deux cas,
on peut y voir le reste à faire,
l’avancée de la production.
Et ce qu’on considère
être un écran de victoire
dans l’écran de gauche,
ça va être le retour sur investissement
dans l’écran de droite.
Des concepts qui sont omniprésents
dans le management
le sont aussi dans ce jeu
et dans la plupart des jeux compétitifs,
comme par exemple
l’optimisation des actifs,
la création de procédures standardisées
et la priorisation des objectifs.
Vous allez me dire :
« Peut-être, mais ces jeux-là,
personne n’y joue,
ce n’est qu’une minorité
dans le jeu vidéo. »
J’aurai le plaisir
de vous dire que c’est faux.
En effet, sur les 13 jeux
avec le plus de joueurs actifs en 2019,
11 d’entre eux étaient des jeux
qui sont qualifiés d’e-sportifs
et deux sont des jeux
que je pourrais qualifier
d’à potentiel d’apprentissage,
comme le premier jeu
que je vous ai présenté tout à l’heure.
Si je suis ici, ce n’est pas
pour vous vendre ces jeux,
ce n’est pas pour que
vous commenciez à y jouer demain.
C’est pour une chose
qui me semble beaucoup plus importante.
Si je suis ici devant vous,
c’est pour vous proposer à tous
de dépasser les frontières.
Des frontières abstraites,
mais bien réelles
qui sont celles de nos a priori
sur le monde du jeu vidéo.
C’est pour vous proposer de demain,
en tant que recruteur,
en tant que professionnel,
peut-être aussi en tant que parent
et déjà aujourd’hui en tant qu’étudiant,
en tant que collègue, ami,
de faire preuve de curiosité
envers les autres.
De voir ce que les passions
des autres leur apportent,
et ce qu’elles peuvent
vous apporter à vous.